today on the matt walsh show many people
are desperately trying to come up with a
rationale to continue wearing a mask now
the cdc has changed its guidance on the
issue we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the nyc pride parade
bans cops from participating a teacher
is caught on camera braiding a student
and 60 minutes is the latest mainstream
media outlet to report on the impending
ufo invasion this is real folks we'll
talk about that plus our daily
cancellation and much and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
well you've heard us talk about how
great the my pillow pillow is uh and it
is if you've never tried it if you've
never experienced the my pillow then
you've gotta you just you don't know
what a good night's sleep is without it
but um
there's also the my slippers that's the
latest thing from my pillows uh from my
pillow and and look they've done it
again the slippers took over two years
to develop and they're designed to wear
indoors and outdoors all day long
uh in fact i don't usually believe in
wearing slippers like out in public but
i was wearing my slippers because i wear
them in the house all day and i had to
run out to the store i forgot i had them
on
and uh so i was i was the guy walking
through the store with the slippers on
that did happen but it's fine because
they're they're made for usage uh
in in any context for a limited time my
pillow is offering forty percent off
their new my slippers yes forty percent
you don't wanna miss out on a deal like
this um so you gotta make sure you take
advantage and me i have their sheets
i've got their pillows i've got the
slippers
uh all of their for all their products
comfort is key and that's what you get
from my slippers so go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener square and
use promo code daily wire you'll also
get deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the giza dream bed
sheets the my pillow mattress topper and
my pillow towel sets or call
800-951-7163 and use promo code
dailywire visit mypillow.com now or call
800-951-7163
so it's been a hard few days for folks
on the anti-science left as we covered
late last week the cdc announced that
vaccinated people can take off their
masks this news was irrelevant to people
like myself who took the mask off long
ago or never wore it to begin with
except when forced to those in our camp
were not waiting for permission from the
cdc nor have we ever claimed that the
cdc is the ultimate unquestionable
authority on all things science for us
the cdc announcing that we could walk
outside and breathe the air without a
mask is like the
food and drug administration announcing
that we're allowed to eat a sandwich for
lunch
like thanks but i wasn't really asking
for your opinion and i don't care
as for science
it is a process
science is not an agency
it's not a department it's not a person
it's not a statement
it's a process through which the natural
world is investigated and its workings
are better understood
that that's all that science is and all
that we should see it as
this is why the phrase trust the science
is itself unscientific because most of
the time when someone says that when
they say trust the science what they
mean is that you should trust the
assertion that they are making in the
name of science
but trusting the science means precisely
that you don't trust the assertion and
instead you look at the process by which
they arrived at their conclusion that's
what science is all about
yet uh
that's that's one big hint right there
anytime someone say oh trust me trust me
on this
um that's that's a good indication that
this is not about science
yet for many on the left science is a
religion and by that i don't mean that
they religiously and rigorously follow
the scientific process to come to their
conclusions obviously not these are the
people after all who think that men can
have babies
so clearly this is not about science no
for them science
is just the label that they have put on
their
preconceived religious doctrines
and because it's a religion
then the supposed scientific authorities
government agencies public health
experts and so on become like high
priests and prophets
they should be trusted and heated not
because they follow the process of
science
but because we're called to have faith
in them as the ordained ministers of the
religion of science
that's the way the left has approached
science especially over the last year
but now there's been a breakdown a a
schism if you will
the priests are waving their holy
scepters and granting millions of people
permission to remove their masks but
many of their disciples don't want to
remove them
for so long they said trust the science
as in trust agencies like the cdc
implicitly and now that's exactly what
they refuse to do
so for example aoc posted on instagram
over the weekend declaring her intention
to continue wearing her mask she said
quote
by the way if you want to keep wearing
your mask then do it personally i'm
going to keep wearing my mask and shared
indoor places like elevators subway
grocery store etc nyc got hit so hard
that i think some of us are going to
take some time adjusting as we feel
comfortable also it's a nice accessory
when you don't want to do all your
makeup
well that part i can relate to obviously
but some democrat-controlled states are
putting the force of law behind this or
keeping the force of law behind it
rather as nj.com reports
governor phil murphy said friday that
new jersey will keep its requirement
that all people must wear masks indoors
in public to protect against the court
of ours at least for now despite federal
health officials releasing updated
guidance that says masks are no longer
needed for fully vaccinated americans in
most circumstances
we're not there yet murphy said a day
after the federal
uh centers for disease control released
its new recommendations though he
stressed the state could drop its
mandate within a matter of weeks if
vaccinations continue to increase and
the state's outbreak keeps receding
massachusetts and hawaii have also
announced that they're going to keep
their mass mandates in place for all
people vaccinated or not
there are like 20 other states that
still have the mandates in place as of
right now
meanwhile many prominent people have
come out and advocated for continued
mass use
mia farrow if she counts as prominent i
don't know tweeted quote hundreds of
people are still dying from covet every
day multiple new variants are out there
although vaccinated i'm still going to
wear my mask in places where others may
be unvaccinated
an epidemiologist with a large social
media following dr eric feigl ding
echoed this sentiment he tweeted
keep wearing the mask
in all caps we card carrying
epidemiologists with formal doctorate in
epidemiology know what we're talking
about vast majority of 700 plus
epidemiologists surveyed says we should
keep wearing the masks for one year or
longer
yes
just one more year
or longer
and as we've seen plenty of people would
be more than happy to indulge
the guardian interviewed a number of
women who plan to continue masking and
indefinitely
and many of them have reasons that have
nothing to do with physical health at
all one woman said that she likes
how masking makes her gender ambiguous
and another said that she likes how it's
um how which you wear the mask wears the
mask it takes away the male gaze
apparently she's under the impression
that the male gaze focuses on the nose
and the mouth and not other parts of the
body
i've also been told that we should keep
wearing a mask because even if not covid
there are still many other germs out
there
and and this excuse is interesting as it
would seem to indicate
that these forever massacre types
just discovered the existence of germs
this past year i mean there were masks
available prior to a year ago
and also plenty of germs out there
and yet
nobody ever even considered walking
around in a mask all day unless they had
some very specific medical reason for
doing so
someone else dave leviton a reporter for
the daily beast
he tweeted at me on sunday to argue that
wearing a mask to cover your face is no
different in principle for wearing pants
and i don't object to people wearing
pants so why should i object to people
wearing masks
what this really tells me is that dave
sees no difference between his face and
his ass
and that may indeed be the case for him
specifically but
i don't think that holds true across the
board
all told what's clear is that lots of
people are going to cling desperately to
their masks for reasons that have
nothing to do with the process of
science at all
but i've pointed all this out many times
before
lots of people have pointed it out
what i'd like to do now is explain
why it bothers me to have healthy people
walking around in masks when it is not
medically necessary
yes i can go out mask list myself and i
have been doing that all along
but why do i care what other people do
why do i have an opinion about that
why should it cause me any uh distress
if we now live in a society where
millions of people will wear masks
everywhere all the time for reasons that
have little to do with health and safety
well because
it is grotesque
and unhuman
it is an attack on and rejection of
society itself
the people who do this they're not only
treating air like it's poison
not only walking around every day as if
they live downwind of chernobyl but
they're treating other human beings like
they are nothing but vessels of disease
and yes
humans can be vessels of disease but by
wearing the mask again when it's not
medically necessary i'm not talking
about somebody on chemo or something
wearing a mask
by wearing the mask you are declaring
that in your mind
other human beings are toxic
to you the most foremost the most
salient fact about other humans
is that they might make you sick
you are living a life steeped in
paranoia and fear and suspicion
literally wearing your neuroses on your
face
and thereby feeding and promoting
paranoia and fear in other people
when you're wearing a mask the first
thing you're saying to everyone you come
across and speak to and interact with is
that they are potentially diseased
they are a danger to you as you are to
them
does that bother me
does it bother me if that's what we're
saying to everyone we see all the time
in perpetuity
yeah it does
you know part of living in a human
society
is
walking down the street
seeing the faces of strangers
being able to look at them
and them at you
a big part of human communication is
body language facial expression
these are major facets of human
existence and human interchange these
aren't small
things there there are people who wish
to take that away permanently
which is to say they want to
fundamentally reshape the way that human
beings interact with each other and see
each other am i opposed to that yes i am
very much so
your here i think is the point
your medically unnecessary mask is not
just a private decision
it's not
um it is a public statement
an arrogant disgraceful repulsive
statement
it's a statement that should be
condemned by all people who wish to live
in a healthy and properly ordered
society
and so that's why i care
and that's why frankly
maybe we should be thinking about uh
considering the
psychological health risks
posed by healthy people wearing
medically unnecessary masks maybe we
should be thinking about about masking
bands that's what we should be calling
for across the country
at least 15 days of a masking band
ban to slow the spread of uh paranoia
and uh and and
ocd across the country that's i think
maybe that's it that's what we need
now let's get to our five headlines
maybe you've had the experience that
i've had many times in my life where
you're you're sitting in a car you're in
the back seat maybe it's a taxi or an
uber or something and you start getting
that or you could be in a plane you
start getting that motion sickness and
uh then panic sets in especially if
you're on a plane because there's no way
they can't pull over for you in that
situation um motion sickness nausea in
general is not fun to deal with and
that's why i'm so grateful that i have
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness but also anxiety migraine
hangover morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug-free it's non-drowsy provides
all-natural relief with zero side
effects the technology was originally
developed in hospitals
but it's now available to the masses and
you got to take advantage of this relief
ban is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that's been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting this year ensure
that nausea is never the reason to miss
out on life's important moments right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for matt walsh listeners if you go
to reliefband.com use promo code walsh
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and no questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code walsh for 20
off
all right so
sort of staying on the same subject here
the cdc director rochelle walensky is uh
obviously an incompetent liar which
means that she fits right in of course
in government in the federal government
but she was on abc
and she had a couple of interesting
things to say i want to play this for
you first sh she makes a a
stipulation she's asked about how many
people have died of covet after getting
the the vaccine
and
she sort of gets around to giving the
number but she makes
a very curious stipulation about those
people and let's see if you pick up on
this let's listen
are you aware of any fully vaccinated
individual who has died of covet 19
we do keep a track of this on our
website we are asking hospitals and and
health care facilities to send us
cases of what we're calling breakthrough
infections they occur they are rare we
are aware of 223
as of may 10th that are
among the 115 million people that had
been vaccinated by that time i also want
to convey that now many many hospitals
are screening people for coveted when
they come in so not all of those 223
cases who had coveted actually died of
covet they may have had mild disease but
died for example of a heart attack so
casey said 223 a hundred cases but no uh
confirmed deaths of people who are
vaccinated
i'm i'm sorry there have been 223 deaths
out of 115
million
people thank you for vaccinated an
extraordinarily extraordinarily low rate
when you consider the death rate of
covet itself
huh
that's interesting
okay so a couple things there
at first it sounds like she she is
trying to say that there have been 223
breakthrough so-called breakthrough
cases of covid
people getting coveted after getting the
vaccine
but then she says that no no those are
the people who died of it
died of covet
so how many actual breakthrough cases
have there been assuming that not every
person with a breakthrough case died
what's the number of breakthrough
breakthrough cases she actually didn't
tell us that but we can assume it's much
much higher
but she also says that
well just because
someone who's been vaccinated
dies with covid doesn't mean they died
of covet
wow
that's
i mean because that sounds ex isn't that
exactly what lots what some of us have
been saying about the covet death rate
all along
like up until just now
to say what she just said there would
have been condemned and was condemned as
anti-science uh conspiracy theory
so on and so forth
many of us right have been wondering
this all along
we've said yes obviously covet is real
obviously it's killing lots of people
but are we
ever
every single person who dies with kovid
does that count as dying of covid
are we conflating these things
there seems to be an indication maybe we
have in some cases
how often has it been conflated
incorrectly
and here she is
admitting it
at least when it comes to the vaccinated
people
because she's saying look anyone who
comes to the hospital and dies we're
gonna run a coveted test and uh and
and
and there might be some people who died
of a heart attack or something they
happen to have covid asymptomatic
doesn't mean they died of it
it's just it's fascinating that now we
hear this from the cdc now they admit
that
and i don't
i i don't uh i don't doubt at all what
you're saying
to me it seems there's a very good
chance that a large portion of those
people who died with covid after getting
vaccinated didn't actually die of covet
i don't know what the number is she's
not telling us
it wouldn't surprise me if it was a
large portion
but then you got to take that logic and
extend it out and start asking that same
question
in general about the covet death rate
but we're not allowed to do that you
can't do that
you're only allowed to do that
when you're doing it
for the purposes of pushing the vaccine
she was also asked about why the cdc
made this change with the masking
guidelines so suddenly and she claimed
that the science has evolved in just two
weeks
let's listen to that
it was just tuesday when you sat before
a senate committee and you were adamant
then that masking and social distancing
should remain in place but the
washington post is reporting you had
already approved a decision to change
the guidance when it was finally
announced on thursday it came as a huge
surprise and left some administration
officials doctors businesses off guard
so why so suddenly and why did you not
tell the senate panel what you had
decided we're at a place in this
pandemic cases have been coming down
more than a third just in the last two
weeks we have vaccine now across this
country widely available for anyone who
wants it and we now have science that
has really just evolved even in the last
two weeks that demonstrates that these
vaccines are safe they are effective
they are working in the population just
as they did in the clinical trials that
they are working against our variants
that we have here circulating in the
united states and that if you were to
develop an infection
even if you got vaccinated that you
can't transmit that infection to other
people some of that science was really
evolving as late as last thursday and
one of the published one of the papers
the largest paper was published from the
cdc just the day before yesterday so we
were actively reviewing that science
during the past week we were making
decisions and moving moving and our
subject matter experts were working just
as i was testifying in front of congress
and those that was what was happening i
told the american people i'd deliver the
science as soon as we had it
deliver the science
what the hell does that even mean
it's got to deliver the science
here's the science you you ordered
special delivery
uh she's lying uh she's this is this is
she's simply lying and these people have
been lying to us from day one
from day one they've been lied they've
been looking into cameras and lying
their asses off to us
that's what that is the science evolved
in the last two weeks no what
what does that mean first of all exactly
did you say
a certain paper was published okay
so you're telling me that
up until
two weeks ago you
you weren't sure whether the vaccine
even worked
so you you've been pushing the vaccine
for months
and getting millions and tens and tens
and tens of millions of people
vaccinated and you weren't even sure if
it was working
that's a little concerning if that's
true
what about other questions about what
about side effects long-term effects
you know you say the vaccine is safe
okay well is that science evolving too
you're saying you just realized two
weeks with no no i'm sorry not even two
weeks ago within the last two weeks
um
and came to the conclusion last week a
few days ago
that the vaccine actually works and so
of course you don't need a mask
well again if that science was quote
evolving
up until a few days ago
then doesn't that raise a lot of very
concerning questions about what else you
don't know
about this substance that you're
injecting into millions of people
now the
the good news here in a certain way is
that uh she's lying and it's it's clear
that she's lying
we've we have known
all along that
vaccinated people don't need to wear
masks
just like we've known a lot of other
things about masking that they've lied
to us about
and this is what they you you could just
follow well i was gonna say follow the
trajectory with masking but it's not
really a trajectory because it's like
it's up and down and schizophrenic all
over the place but what they've told us
about masks
originally saying
nobody needs to wear it and then
everyone needs to wear it and then just
back and forth all over the place
have they been
following the science that whole time
no
they've been following something else
uh largely politics
so if they're following the science here
it's political science that they are
that they're following
the other thing that we've been expected
to believe
over the last year
is that
um
we we have known almost nothing about
how medical masks work
up until this last year
and over the last year we've been
you know the scientists and the public
health experts have been
researching it and figuring it out and
it's been evolving and everything else
medical masks have been around forever
there's not much that we've actually
learned about them in the last year that
we didn't know prior to a year ago
and that's an important point because it
shows again that when the so-called
public health experts have been all over
the map
in their masking guidance
it's not because they're trying to
figure out if masks work and what they
do exactly and all of this we've known
what a mask is and what function it
serves and all that we've known that
um it's more that they've been
calibrating their own political needs
that's what all this is about
that's what it's always been about
all right number two from the daily wire
it says heritage of pride the
organization that hosts new york city's
annual lgbt pride parade voted to ban
police from participating in the 2021
pride parade even going so far as to
cancel the annual march of lgbt new york
police department officers and is
working to reduce the presence of law
enforcement because the nypd quote
represents violence
it's not clear whether heritage of pride
has the authority to force law
enforcement to draw down its presence at
the parade given that new york city has
seen an increasing crime rate and the
pride parade is traditionally a large
event but the organization believes it
does have the authority to ban officers
from participating in the parade
according to abc quote police will be
banned from participating in nyc pride
events including its signature lgbtq
march until 2025.
nyc pride is also working to reduce the
new york police department's security
and first responder presence at its
events
according to the organization
and andre thomas of heritage of pride
said quote we know many lgbt cops but
what the institution represents
sometimes to a person of color or trans
person is violence and that doesn't make
you feel safe
so that's the perspective we're coming
from and it's a difficult place to be
but we know that that's what our
community expects from us at this time
uh you know i only think i'll say to
that is that uh
i
first of all i'm not crazy about cops
participating in the pride parade anyway
but really
doing you a favor i guess if you're
banned from participating in the pride
parade
because it's not really the kind of
spectacle you you should want to be a
part of anyway
you know
traditionally
pride is
considered a sin it's not something that
you celebrate
it is the the pride parade
explicitly is a is a celebration of
vanity it's a hey everyone look at me
moment
and even leaving aside what you're
expressing what you're expressing pride
in your sexual orientation
how can you even be proud of that what
is that an accomplishment
but no it's not an accomplishment so
this is
you know there's a certain there is
yeah we use the word pride it could be
used in a couple different ways
um you know we could talk about as a
father i'm proud of my kids
that's a good kind of pride
you could be proud
of
an achievement you know
if you accomplish something you've been
working really hard towards
that's good good pride
but the kind of pride at a pride parade
is neither of those
you're not expressing pride in another
person you're not expressing pride over
an accomplishment of some kind
uh no this is the sinful pride this is
the bad pride
this is the pride this is vanity is what
it is
so if you're banned from participating
as a police officer or anyone else take
that as a blessing
not something you should want to be
associated with in the first place uh
number three here's viral video of a
teacher in wisconsin berating a student
who says he's vaccinated because the
student's not wearing a mask
and you know of course we're really glad
to have these people back in the
classroom now because our children
needed these people so badly
uh and finally you know we've we've uh
reunited them and at least in many
schools across the country and that's
what leads to stuff like this
i don't care if you're vaccinated
okay
i don't want to get sick and die okay
there's other people you can infect just
because you're vaccinated you know what
you're not a special person around here
you should hear about how everybody
talks about you i don't know sure talk
to me i don't care you're a jerk okay
and you need to have respect for other
people in your life
i do you're not a big man on campus
teachers
real you know they're they're they're
just selfless heroes
you gotta respect and love teachers so
much
i mean these people have had they
they've had the year off
you just got like a 12-month vacation
and you're already screaming at your
students
you're already burnt out
you should hear how everyone talks
around you nobody likes you what this is
the teacher saying that
that's the kind of stuff you would
expect but not accept from the teenagers
in the classroom
of course the real uh and i thought the
student handled the the uh berating
pretty pretty well you know uh he was
the calm
rational insane one which which is what
you you so often find in these
classrooms that the the students are
are the more rational ones unfortunately
but the real irony here and if you if
you couldn't see the video then you
didn't pick up on the real irony but um
the irony is that the teacher is
morbidly obese
pretty clearly from from the video
uh so she's morbidly obese and she's
worried that she's gonna die
because of that student sitting across
the room
she she's worried that that's what's
going to kill her the student
even though i
i'm going to assume that she's
vaccinated
right i'll i'll make that assumption
and if she's not vaccinated because she
didn't want to be she could be
vaccinated by now so we'll just assume
that she is
um especially if she's concerned that
everyone around her is going to get her
sick and make her die so
she's vaccinated and yet she's
assuming she's vaccinated the kid is
vaccinated
what what does she think is gonna happen
no as we've been saying here for a while
it's
uh
you're morbidly obese
the health concern especially if you're
vaccinated now the health concern that
you that you need to worry about is not
covet
and even before you were vaccinated yeah
you did need to be worried about covet
but the main reason you had to worry
about it is because of how covet affects
obese people and they were the you know
took the brunt along with the elderly
of the deaths and the serious side
effects and everything
so if you're that concerned maybe stop
screaming at the student and um
i don't know
lay off the fast food hamburgers
for a few months
lose a few pounds if you're that worried
just a thought
uh
all right 60 minutes i got to play this
um 60 minutes had a report on
i know some of you are sick of me
talking about this subject but you're
just gonna have to deal with it because
this matters and this is important
60 minutes had a report on all of the
ufo encounters that we've been hearing
about uh in the lead up to the report
that's going to be given to congress
in the next month or so from
the defense department about about all
of this
i thought one interview that was
especially compelling
and the whole thing from 60 minutes is
worth watching but one interview was
especially compelling it was from two
navy pilots part of a team of four
who personally with their own eyes
observed one of these things up close
and here they are
talking about it
on november 14th fraver and dietrich
each with a weapon system officer in the
backseat were diverted to investigate
they found an area of roiling white
water the size of a 737 in an otherwise
calm blue sea
so
as we're looking at this
her backseater says hey skipper do you
and about that got out i said dude do
you see that thing down there and we saw
this little white
tic tac looking object and it's just
kind of moving above the white water
area as dietrich circled above fravor
went in for a closer look sort of
spiraling down the tic tacs don't point
north-south it goes
and just turns abruptly and starts
mirroring me so as i'm coming down
it starts coming up so it's it's
mimicking your moves yeah it wasn't
where we were there
he said it was about the size of his
f-18 with no markings no wings no
exhaust plumes too i'll see how close i
can get
so i go like this and it's climbing
still
and when it gets right in front of me it
just disappears
disappeared disappears like gone
it had sped off
what are you thinking
so your mind tries to make sense of it
i'm going to categorize this as
maybe a helicopter or maybe a drone
and when it disappeared i mean it was
just did your backseaters see this too
yeah oh yeah there was four of us in the
airplanes literally watching this thing
for roughly about five minutes
okay what else do you want
what else do you want
i mean that is okay so you've got four
eyewitnesses
that see not it's not like they saw this
thing speed across the sky in a blur
in two seconds they they're observing it
up close for five minutes
so you've got four eyewitnesses
uh
we should note expert eyewitnesses these
are navy pilots and their job is to
observe and and detect
um
you know threats in the sky so
four expert eyewitnesses
observing this phenomenon for
a sustained period of time
and
their uh
what they witness their testimony is
confirmed by radar and by video
and we have some of the video that you
know you can watch in 60 minutes played
some of that video too so
that's
that's about as
persuasive as evidence could possibly be
you know for a long time the complaint
about
these ufo sightings
is that uh all of the you know it's like
if this was really happening we would
expect more evidence than just some
farmer in kansas who
says that he saw this thing and nobody
else saw it and he didn't have a camera
or he did have a camera but it was a
camera from
you know somehow a camera from the civil
war era or something like that um
and that was my complaint about it but
now we're getting
the kind of evidence
that you would expect
if these things were really happening in
our skies
so does that prove that it's uh alien
technology no but
it it it does prove that
there's something going on
this is not a figment of anyone's
imagination
this is not these are not weather
balloons okay this is not hallucination
it wasn't like all four of those pilots
were hallucinating the same thing at the
same time
um
and these are we know that these are
some kinds of vehicles that are out
there and they're they they are doing
things that seem impossible that seem
even to break the laws of physics as we
understand them
i i think i think that much we can say
with a hundred percent certainty
everything i just said now as far as
where the thing are from and what
they're doing and all of that well of
course we can't speak with anything
close to certainty on that but
it is uh
it's something
and and i and i i continue to i i'm not
sold on the alien technology part of it
but
other than that what is it russia china
has this kind of technology my problem
with that theory
that it's some foreign
power that has this sort of technology
um
is that these kinds of sightings first
of all go back
you know well really they go back many
decades
um
and it just makes you wonder if if some
foreign adversary has this kind of
technology technology that's
centuries
beyond our capabilities
then why aren't they doing more than
just buzzing around in the sky over the
ocean
why haven't they already invaded and
destroyed us or or you know
subjugated us
why aren't we a slave state to china if
china has this kind of technology
so i don't know and you could you could
use that same argument with uh with the
space alien theory and say well what are
they doing why haven't they invaded by
now so who knows
um that's space aliens okay
we also have around the same time
there's been an uptick of bigfoot
sightings as well and i got to play this
for you because this uh well first
here's here's the report from daily
caller it says a user on tick tock has
blown up after claiming to have evidence
of humanoids living in the wild
tick tock user chronicles of olivia
released several videos which have
generated millions of views in the past
few days about these humanoids in the
wild that the government allegedly knows
about the biggest piece of evidence she
provided was a photo of a footprint at
lena lake in washington
um
and it's a lot she's like this long tick
tock series and i did
because i'm a loser with nothing better
to do i watched the entire thing i'm not
going to subject you to all of it
but here's a quick uh clip of her
talking about her experience with
bigfoot or what maybe not bigfoot but
some kind of
humanoid half ape creatures living in
the woods let's watch
so the encounter that my mom and i had
um became a case we were contacted by a
reporter
and there are things that the government
knows about that i know that the public
does not know they keep this a secret
and i understand because they don't want
to scare people i get it that's
understandable but there are creatures
there are humanoids that live in these
national parks that are not yet
classified as a species yet i walked to
the edge of this mud embankment and i
was standing there in complete
awe because
this whole entire area and you can even
see the the the indents in the mud there
were hundreds and hundreds of footprints
but like they were the weirdest
footprints i had ever seen so here's the
photo
and you're probably wondering wow that
was pointless it's literally a human
footprint no one cares
exactly
guys
this right here this ridge
right here
is called a mid tarsal break ah
human footprints do not have the old
mid-tarsal brake brake and this
footprint contains a mid-tarsal break
so what mid-tarsal break means is that
the outer parts of the foot bend at the
middle this is only found in primates
the foot bones of an ape don't lock
together in the same way okay it does i
think that's that's pretty much it we
just cut it there
and she goes on into greater detail but
uh that's basically it the the
mid-tarsal
the mid-tarsal break okay uh i mean i
can't
how else could you explain those
footprints with a little line across
them
it's there's no other way to explain it
obviously it's bigfoot
how else could you get a footprint with
a line across it
i can think of no other possible
explanation
no see i i think when i when i started
playing this maybe some of you were
worried that i had gone way off the
reservation and i was about to start
endorsing bigfoot too but uh this is
where i where i
uh pun intended this is where i draw the
line much like i think she drew the line
on that footprint uh i draw the line at
the bigfoot stuff i don't
i i would love to believe it don't get
me wrong that would be great that'd be a
lot of fun if there was actually bigfoot
living out in the woods uh so i want to
believe it i'm a willing
you know listener
i'm an eager and willing listener like
any time someone says they have evidence
of bigfoot i'm sitting here like okay
convince me i i want to be convinced
but
no they never never this this is one
same objection that you get with ufos
although as i said i think that the
objection for ufos doesn't hold anymore
because we do have really good evidence
but
uh with with bigfoot you would expect
if there are there's not just one but a
whole race a whole species of these
giant
half-man half-ape creatures living in
the woods in the continental united
states
you would expect
something
by now some really really compelling
evidence not a footprint with a line
drawn across it
and not like once again
the the grainy photo from with
taken by a camera from
you know the same camera that was using
the gettysburg address
like
clear video everyone walks around now
with high definition cameras in their
pockets so video something
uh maybe
why hasn't anyone ever stumbled across
like an encampment
of these things a burial site
anything
so i can't i can't go there with bigfoot
yet as much as i would like to um i'm
not there all right let's move now to
reading the youtube comments
pink butterfly referring to bill de
blasio trying to sell vaccines by
promising free fast food pink butterfly
says
wait a minute i thought we weren't
supposed to use food as a reward
at least that's what almost every child
psychologist has been saying for years
do the child psychologist say that
because i use food as a reward sometimes
with my kids
i'll give you a snack if you do this or
that i don't you know what and i don't
even care if i i understand oh you're
not supposed to do that that's doesn't
matter you know what you know what
parenting is parenting is
you just get through every every day
you make the best
decisions you can in the moment
i don't care what the child
psychologists say i don't care about the
parenting books
doesn't matter to me
um
all right int jerk says they might as
well say that after you get the vaccine
the doctor will give you a free lollipop
for being such a good and brave little
boy
i would be more motivated by that
frankly than i would by the uh
by the fast food coupon
linda says i sometimes forget matt is so
young he speaks with such knowledge and
wisdom that he should be around 60.
well i am i'm 64
years old
mac miller says i was listening to this
matt yelled hit like like now and i had
to get on youtube and like it out of
sheer terror well that's good so hit
like hit it right now
oh
sorry
might be getting a little overboard i
just hurt my hand a little that actually
did hurt
uh
alice jones says
uh hold on a second where are we
oh matthew says matt on the survey i had
to put wardrobe as the thing i leak i
like least about the show
you got to do better
so these surveys i've been telling
people to fill out they're they're
asking you what you like least
about the show
i would never have told you to fill it
out if i knew if i knew it was gonna be
hurtful things like that
they didn't they didn't tell me that
here when they said oh you got to tell
people to fill out the survey
they didn't tell i was soliciting
insults against myself
um and uh let's see i thought there was
more but i guess that's it
oh geralyn says i really appreciate the
irony of matt yelling and demanding we
hit the like button and moments later
introducing ben shapiro's book the
authoritarian moment well
yeah well you know but but i'm also a
theocratic fascist so what do you expect
you get what you expect from me
well if your dream is coming to
nashville on the daily wires dime to
meet candace owens then uh look i've
already lived your dream and i can tell
you how great it is but more importantly
candace owens has lived the dream of
meeting me i think i think she would
agree with that if you asked her
but don't ask her uh lucky for you your
dream might actually come true if you
sign up as a daily wire member with code
vip you'll get 20 off your new
membership and be automatically entered
for a chance to win a trip to the daily
wire studios to see candace live
not only will you be meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio our office and front row seats to
watch her live and in action on her talk
show candace so don't wait go enter to
win a candace vip pass now at
dailywire.com subscribe using
promo code vip for 20 off and for an
experience that only
joe biden could forget
um
also
as just mentioned
uh you know we're we're moving things
along here at the daily wire we're
growing very fast but we want to hear
from you
so go to dailywire.com walsh and fill
out my audience survey to tell us a
little bit more about yourself
is this about you or is it about me
okay we want to hear about you we don't
we don't need to hear your opinion of me
right
and if you're you have opinions they
should be good opinions
because i do i am going to be seeing all
these results
it would cause my my ego to just crash
and burn in flames if you don't say nice
things anyway um to sweeten the whole
experience those of you that uh that
fill out the survey you get entered to
win a 1 000 gift card you can only get
the uh be eligible for the gift card per
survey that you fill out you can only
fill it survey once per show so if you
want to be eligible more than once you
got to listen to ben shapiro michael
knowles and andrew clavin to get access
to their surveys as well again my survey
link is dailywire.comwalsh
we'd love to hear from you but make sure
that you're nice now let's get to our
daily cancellation
today i'm very excited to cancel a
momentously deserving individual named
brittany james md and brittany james md
is certainly the kind of md who wants
you to always acknowledge the md when
addressing her she describes herself in
her bio as an anti-racist feminist a
physician and activist and a scholar
it probably tells you all you need to
know that she lists anti-racist
feminists before physician she also
lists her pronouns as expected but
bernie james md tweeted this a couple
days ago she said
my doing my own business shopping and a
middle-aged white woman asked me if i
worked there when i looked at her
blankly and answered back in a deadpan
voice no
she giggled it off and said i was just
wondering where to put this shirt back
but i'm a bad person if i go off
well no you're not a bad person if you
go off you're a bad person in general um
and also you're a bad person if you go
off but she continues
kicking myself for not saying i'm a
physician and letting her die of
embarrassment but something tells me she
wouldn't even have the decency to be
embarrassed most of these types don't
stop asking black people why they are
angry i can't even shop in peace
the worst part about everyday racism of
white folks is that we aren't even
allowed to be angry about it as a black
woman
it would have it would have come back on
me i'm tired
now after reading this i very much want
to see dr james at a retail store so
that i can ask her if she works there
and then when she says i'm a physician
i'll say sure you are sweetheart now now
tell me what where do
i get the laundry detergent
and i would like to say that to her just
to annoy her because annoying entitled
jerks is a virtuous act in my opinion
and i do believe in knowing entitled
jerks equally and inequitably by the way
i don't care about your race or your sex
my disdain for entitled jerks knows no
demographic boundaries
in fact in this case we should stipulate
that we're dealing with an entitled
elitist jerk
because what she's really saying here is
that retail workers are beneath her
she quite clearly feels that she belongs
to a social strata far above that of a
lowly customer service worker and a name
tag
something tells me that if someone heard
her and saw her and assumed that she was
a rocket scientist or an architect or
something she wouldn't be nearly as
traumatized so this is more than
anything about her own fragile ego and
the social caste system that she has
concocted in her head and of course
placed herself at the top of
now me
i'm not offended when people confuse me
with an employee at a store i i don't
consider myself to be superior in any
way to the guy stocking shelves at
walmart so if somebody thinks i'm that
guy fine what do i care
and yes i have been asked the do you
work here question many times in my life
admittedly not as much recently and i
think that's partly because
when i'm at a store these days most of
the time
i'm shopping off of a list that my wife
gave me and the list is about the length
of like the dead sea scrolls and i'm
walking around the aisles
looking somewhat frantic and bewildered
and obsessively going back to my phone
as a reference point
the point is i just don't have the vibe
of a guy who works in the facility every
day and knows where everything is
but back in my younger days of shopping
just for myself
and and knowing exactly what i wanted
and where it was because everything i
wanted was in the frozen food section
i got confused with workers much more
often
that's that's because when someone makes
this mistake
they're responding if anything if
they're responding to anything they're
responding to your demeanor
and often the clothes that you're
wearing
and maybe some other signifiers that
have nothing to do with race
i probably wouldn't ever be mistaken for
an employee at hot topic or victoria's
secret because in those places i would
stick out like well like a bearded guy
in his mid-30s at hot topic or
victoria's secret it's not racial though
not everything is racial in fact most of
the things that people think are racial
these days actually aren't
so what we have here is yet another
example of a person with a racial
framework
a person who sees everything through a
racial lens
and who assumes that everybody else does
the same in her mind
anything that could theoretically be
racism
must be racism
it's not just the first explanation she
jumps to but it's the only explanation
she has categorically ruled out all
other potential causes
and she's done this again in spite of
the fact that the interaction she
describes hasn't has happened to
everyone
it's totally normal and it's not a big
deal
by the way if you want to test this out
then just imagine a white man
in a red shirt at target have you ever
gone to target in a red shirt
or a blue shirt at best buy
standing next to a black man in a white
shirt or a gray shirt or something who
do you think is going to get stopped by
someone who assumes that they're an
employee
or we could do it this way a white guy
in a collared shirt with a tie and
khakis and a black guy in pajama pants
who gets the angry older woman coming
over to him and saying excuse me are you
the manager
clearly not the guy in pajamas no matter
his race
in fact you could argue that getting
confused for an employee is a compliment
because maybe you were the only person
in the store who wasn't dressed like a
slob who just woke up with a hangover 12
minutes ago
but there's another part of this aside
from the racial obsessions of brittany
here the real driver is not even that
but but more so just garden variety
narcissism narcissism
she is someone who assumes and there are
a lot of people like this out there
that every banal annoyance she
encounters must be unique must be
targeted
must be sinister
must be all about her somehow
she doesn't want to think that this is
this is the sort of thing that happens
to everybody
partly because it would destroy her
racial narrative but even more because
it would destroy the narrative that she
keeps closer to the heart the narrative
that she is the center of the world and
everything that happens to her really
matters
everything is a big deal
if she were to admit that this is an
everyday completely normal utterly
unremarkable event then she's not only
deprived of an opportunity to feel
wounded but also she must admit that her
life isn't quite as unique as she
assumed and hoped
here's one thing i'll guarantee i
guarantee that britney
is the kind of person
who honks
while stuck in traffic on the highway
everybody sitting in the same traffic
jam everyone is suffering the same
inconvenience nobody likes it
but there's always that person honking
as if she is the main character of the
traffic jam and all the other cars are
conspiring to prevent her from getting
to her pilates class on time
everybody else is in her way she's not
in their way
they're in her way i mean why is there
traffic on the road in the first place
well because lots of people are trying
to go in the same direction at the same
time
that's also why nobody has the right to
be angry about it everybody is part of
the problem
but brittany can't see it that way
bernie's also the sort of person who
comes home at night and inflicts her
self-centered miseries on whoever has
the misfortune of living with her she'll
go into long drawn-out epic stories
describing every irritation she
experienced that day
explaining how everyone is out to get
her all the time the world is so unfair
and so on
what she really needs
but probably doesn't have
is some kind-hearted compassionate
person to say to her
hey brittany
shut up
you're not special you're not a victim
the only thing unique about you is that
you handle inconvenience much worse than
average than the average person
other than that your life is exceedingly
average
your experiences are not incredible or
even interesting
and so i'm gonna leave now and i'll let
you continue ranting to the wall because
i suspect it'd be all the same to you
anyway
brittany needs to hear that
lots of people do but like lots of
people she never has until now
so you're welcome brittany
and also
of course you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 corporations
drop mask mandates israel bombs and
associated press building and liz cheney
hence had a 2024 presidential campaign
check it out on the michael knolls show